I'll start with dot append and dot
prepend which you might remember from
the JavaScript basics resume project
these add children to an element so if I
select this Dom element of the first
article item I can call dot append or
prepend and this new element will be
added as a child to this one Dada Pen
adds this new element as the last child
of the selected item while dot pre pen
adds this new element as the first child
of the selected item when we test this
code we can see some cute puppies at the
beginning of article one and at the end
of article one but what if I wanted this
element to have a sibling for that I'll
use insert before or insert after as you
may guess insert before adds a sibling
before the current element and insert
after adds a sibling after the current
element you know what why don't you give
these a try